What is Functions as a Service, or
FaaS as it is more commonly known as.
Are FaaS and Serverless the same
thing, or are they different?
Hi I'm Jason Goode with IBM Cloud team,
I'm going to answer those questions for you
today, but before we go too FaaS, please make
sure to hit that subscribe button. All right,
I'm excited to get into let's take a step back
and look at a time before we had cloud. So back
in the day an organization would have to manage
their whole IT software stack on premises. So,
let's take a look at that. So at the
bottom here you would have your Hardware,
and this would be all your compute, your
network, and your storage resources.
And then moving on up we'd
have our Virtualization layer,
and essentially what happens here is you'd be
virtualizing all those hardware resources with
something say like a hypervisor to create modular
virtual machines so you can horizontally scale.
And then moving on up, we then
move into our Operating System.
And I'm sure most of you
are aware of what this is,
this would be the software that's actually
on your computer and enables programs to run.
And then on top of that we run into our Runtime,
and this would really be the glue between your
Operating System and your Application and be the
environment that your Application operates in. And
then last but not least, we have our Application.
And this would be where all the magic happens. So
this would be your business logic, right. And
this is where your development team will spend
most their time, because this is where they
design, build, and deploy your application.
So, as you can see this is quite a bit for one
organization to maintain and own, you know up
front you have a lot of costs with your hardware
and you're not very agile, say something goes down
in this IT stack here, I mean it could affect any
of these given layers. And the time to provision
and get your application out the door could
take anywhere from a week to even a month.
So not very efficient. So, let's fast forward
to the early 2000's and AWS emerged with
a new cloud computing service model, which is
Infrastructure as a Service, also known as IaaS.
And what IaaS does it actually
abstracts these lower layers,
these infrastructure layers, which you can now run
from a cloud service provider and it's a common
model used today. So it's much more cost efficient
without having to own and maintain these layers
and you can provision and get your application
out the door much quicker. So, we're looking
at anything from an hour to minutes, which is a
huge increase from that week to month timeline.
So then we also had another cloud computing
service model emerged which is Platform as
a Service. And as you can see we even took
the abstraction level even further with PaaS,
so with this model now you're just worried about
your application, that's all you have to maintain.
And the idle time is much shorter too, so
you'd be running at least one server but
you don't have to worry about your Runtime,
your Operating System, just that Application.
And the time to provision and get
your application out the door is much
shorter as well, so you're looking
anything from minutes to seconds.
All right. So you're probably wondering, okay,
so we're at the Application layer, how can we
abstract even further. Well let me explain. So
back in 2014, hook.io emerged with a new cloud
computing service model which is the topic of the
hour, and that is Functions as a Service, also
known as FaaS. And what FaaS does it abstracts
that Application, so now you can only focus on the
Functions. And the functions are the individual
components that actually make up that application.
So, it'd be the individual tasks you know
something like uploading an image file,
you just have so much more flexibility and
you have zero idle time. So you don't even
need a server, that's all managed and taken
care for you by the cloud service provider.
It's much more cost effective, and the time
to provision with Function as a Service
is lightning fast. So we're looking at
anywhere from a second to millisecond.
So I know I went through this pretty quick,
but hopefully you can get a sense of how
Functions as a Service relates to the other cloud
computing service models within this landscape.
Oh I'm sorry, I should actually take a step
back, we should talk about Software as a Service
briefly. So that's another cloud computing
service model that actually abstracts all
these layers here, including the functions. And
you know, that would be something like YouTube,
if you're watching this video that would be an
example of Software as a Service. So now let's
take a look at how Functions as a Service relates
to Serverless and take a look at the architecture.
All right. So, Functions as a Service, is actually
a key subset of Serverless, as well as Backend as
a Service. Backend as a Service is any third party
service that you integrate with your application
and the great thing about it is there's no code
that you need to manage, and there's no servers.
So let's take a look at what a Serverless
application architecture might look like
and let's use an example of something oh I
don't know let's say a hair color for gray hair
eCommerce storefront, which I've never looked into
before. Okay. So we'll start here with our client,
and this would be our hair color eCommerce
website. And let's say we have a user
and they click and they want to see
some before and after images. So
we would have a request come down here and we
would have a third party Object Storage Service.
And, the great thing about this is there is no
servers involved once again. So this would be
one example of Backend as a Service. And it would
use something like HTML, it could be Javascript,
or CSS and it would actually send those images
back to the client. So now that they've looked
at some before and after images, now we need
to get them authenticated. So we can again have
another third party service integrated and we
could have this as an Authentication Service.
Okay, so this would be one more example of
Backend as a Service, but now let's let's take
a look at Functions as a Service and let's say
that the client needs to get their account. So
we'd have another request come and this would
interact with what we call an API Gateway.
And this API Gateway would then invoke a function.
And we'll call this function GetAccount.
And this GetAccount function will now
communicate with a different
database, and this would be Customer
Database.
So, this would be our Functions as a Service,
right here. So this would be one individual
task within the greater application. So
let's do another one. Let's say the Client
makes another request and now they want to see you
know what kind of hair color options they they're
working with, right. So we'd have another
request go through the API Gateway and this
would have another individual function and this
would be Available, if i could spell ha, Color.
Okay. So this FunctionAvailableColor
would go to a separate database
and we'll call this Color Database,
Color DB.
All right. So, this is again, just a very
simplified view into a Serverless Application
Architecture and I mainly want to focus in on
the Function as a Service functions right here.
So let's just zoom in right now, and we'll look
at the API Gateway and our functions and expand.
And expand this out as well, the API Gateway.
So API Gateway, it translates requests to
a single endpoint and then routes it to a
different Functions as a Service function.
So in our case our user makes
requests, right. So we have Get / api
/ color. This API Gateway notices the requests
and it sees AvailableColorFunction over here
because it has Available Color route within the
API Gateway. So again, Functions as a Service
is essentially a small piece of code written by
developer that are executed in the cloud and run
on stateless containers. And what this means is
that they do their job and then they disappear.
And this leads me to my first key benefit I want
to highlight, which is you only pay for what you
use. Because unlike our other cloud computing
service models if you recall, you always got to
pay for some idle time. Even a platform as service
you're responsible for at least one single server.
Another key benefit is you
can just focus on that code,
right. So without the underlying infrastructure,
which is going to be a common theme,
you know throughout this whole video, is you
could just focus on those individual functions
from splitting up that server and that
business logic where you don't have to
worry about maintaining it with
that underlying infrastructure.
Another key benefit is auto acaling. So again,
without that infrastructure you can scale on
demand, automatically, and instantaneously,
right. So if your Function as a Service platform
has demand go down, it'll
automatically scale down for you.
The last but not least highlight I want to
mention is that it's inherently highly available.
So by being spread across multiple availability
zones in different geographical regions,
you can deploy your Function as a Service platform
in those different regions at no incremental cost.
So I know this is just a quick overview of
Functions as a Service, but hopefully you
can now see some of the key benefits as well
as how it relates to Serverless and other
cloud computing service models. Thank you. If you
have any questions please drop us a line below.
If you want to see more videos like this
in the future, please like and subscribe.
And don't forget you can grow your skills
and earn a badge with IBM CloudLabs,
which are free browser-based
interactive Kubernetes labs.